I'm excited to try on her dress I never
really like thought that I would ever
wear you know what I really don't know
what to expect probably not going to get
emotional
sorry but I don't know Kay might cry and
I might not cause I'm definitely gonna
cry it was a nice dress for $25 it'd be
like a $40 dress today
right my mother-in-law wore it in 1952
and then I wore in 1987 and so this will
be the third time it's been put on by
somebody in our family this dress was
meant to be just a symbol of dreams and
hopes and what I wanted for for my life
so mother turn around okay you can't and
up to grandmama oh my god I look like
you there so your arms are longer than
mine I think you look great
I feel like Keira Knightley did in a
good way there's nothing bad ever about
feeling like here Knightley I just like
this looks like a the night gown of a
queen eating the 1700s obviously it
doesn't fit so I couldn't like wear it
like I could just go like this right now
and just bust the whole thing open
I do think it's like really pretty Oh
mom I used to idolize my mom when I was
a kid and I just remember her looking so
gorgeous like a Barbie so it's really
interesting to be in this I never
thought that I'd wear it
I think it's really nice dress um I did
a nice trip wasn't a like Lifetime movie
moment here no I cried no so when are
you gonna get married
nice Jenny mom it was very emotional for
me just to think that she might try on
my dress and it was just nerve-wracking
to think of this step in her life oh my
god mom if it would have fit me like
perfectly or something I think it might
have been a different experience like Oh
like I just could see myself walking
down the aisle but like this is more
like I'm playing dress-up when I'm 10
years old there's something I expect to
see you in a dress like this maybe when
I'm in a nursing home that's upsetting I
don't think that's a question I think
that you wear this yeah - yeah
I actually think you did cuz I think
that the Hat makes it
oh my mom totally wore it better my mom
for sure know how gorgeous she totally
worried no I think she's good when you
kick when I saw you with the veil it's
actually kind of funny like yeah that
made me look like the Bride of
Frankenstein that's what I thought when
I first saw you but I don't want to say
that I'm gonna offend you but yeah